Okay. Welcome back to Gary's Economics.
Today
we are going to talk about
revenue raising and redistribution.
Okay.
Today I'm going to dispel
a couple of the common myths about tax.
So we exist
in a country and increasingly
a world where governments
can't pay for the things they need
00:00:20,760 --> 00:00:22,960
because they don't have any money.
So people are talking about how can we raise money?
And when I talk about taxing the rich,
people think that it's mainly about revenue raising.
This is true.
It's true.
Increasingly we are in a situation
where the middle class are very squeezed
and they don't have much money.
So if you want to actually provide
decent public services,
you have to go after the very rich.
But I don't actually push for taxation
because I want to raise revenue.
The reason I push for taxation
is because ever since I was a trader in the early 2000,
I realised that the economy wouldn’t recover
because wealth was being transferred
very quickly from the middle class
and from government to the super rich.
If the middle class loses its wealth
and the government loses its wealth,
the economy will lose its spending
power, wages will collapse,
the rich will become very rich,
and asset prices will go through the roof.
This is the world we are living in.
Unless you are very rich,
your family and your government is losing its wealth
and you are becoming poor.
For me, tax, whilst revenue raising is a factor,
tax is primarily
about protecting ordinary people
from the rich and stopping wealth transfer
from ordinary people to the rich.
Listen, unless you're very rich,
the assets you own now
will not be owned by your kids and your grandkids.
Those assets will pass to the very rich
because they have enormous amounts of passive income,
which their kids can use to outcompete your kids.
And your kids will end up owning nothing.
This is what I'm trying to avoid.
For me,
taxation is about protecting
the assets
of ordinary British families
and Americans and Australians
and all the other guys who are watching the channel.
It's not just about revenue
raising, tax is about defence,
defence, defence, defence.
I want you to view tax as equivalent to an army.
You have an army to defend yourself from other armies.
You have taxes to protect yourself from the rich.
We had taxes for a long time, and people like my dad
and my friends
dad could afford houses, your kids
and your grandkids will not be able to afford houses
because those houses will be bought by the rich.
The only way to protect yourself from
that is to tax the rich more.
It's not about revenue raising, it's about defence.
The next point is redistribution.
A lot of people don't like my channel
because they think I'm a communist
who is calling for redistribution.
I'm not calling for redistribution.
The redistribution is happening.
I'm trying to stop the redistribution.
Every year,
every decade, every generation,
the middle class and governments get poorer
and those assets gets transferred to the rich.
The government and ordinary families
end up deeper and deeper in debt to the rich.
This is a redistribution.
The redistribution is happening.
The middle class is dying.
They are being eaten by the rich.
I'm not trying to redistribute wealth.
I'm trying to stop the redistribution of wealth
so that your kids and your grandkids
can have something to have kids of their own.
So to conclude, tax is not about revenue raising alone.
It's about defending yourself from the rich.
Redistribution from the rich to the poor
and the ordinary
might be nice in an ideal world,
but right now the main thing is to stop them
from eating your assets alive.
Protect yourself
from the rich, raise taxes on the super rich,
the hoarders of wealth, lower
taxes on ordinary working people.
Tell your friends, tell your mum, support the channel.
Thank you.